I think you know you've been like the
best greatest helper let's go let's go
good morning guys it has been about five
days since the last time I picked up a
camera so I broke my streak dang it what
you have missed in the last five days
has been quite a bit so by me not
picking up the camera I've actually been
a lot more production from around the
house today's Tuesday March 24th on
Friday
that's when Mama and Papa Chan they went
back to Dallas early in the morning and
then Casey
Isaac and I just stayed at home we wrote
some bikes we did a lot of things around
the house which I'll show you everything
that we've done since Friday we have not
left we have been completely at home
other than you know bike riding around
the neighborhood but we haven't gone to
the store Casey hasn't gone to go get
another haircut I haven't gone to go get
my nails done this one fell out so I
planed that painted it black so that's
where we're at with that so it's been
five days straight of us just being here
getting a little bit of cabin fever but
we're surviving we're doing okay
yesterday Isaac started his distance
learning which means he needs to log on
his Chromebook on a Google classroom and
then his teacher he has three teachers
yet three teachers and so his teachers
are all giving him homework assignments
and he has been so good like he's waking
up before even I do and then by the time
I go check up on him he's already
working on his homework so I'm like dude
you're such a good kid well like how did
I get so lucky but he is so responsible
he's been on top of his homework and I
love the fact that we're in the future
because immediately if he has a quiz or
something immediately he gets the test
results back I'm like dude you're doing
great he has like nothing my Asian B's
for I'm like wow all those years and
then after school program really paid
off but yeah he's been doing good right
now this morning I got woken up because
IKEA delivered Isaac's bedroom set so
it's finally in and it was interesting
because when they got here they just
started leaving all the packages on the
front door and usually like they'll
bring it in or because I'll ask you like
oh what room does this belong to
belong in and then they'll bring it
inside and then put it in that room but
not this time
now the world is different and so they
were just leaving packages in the front
they had masks on the gloves and and
then Casey ended up opening the door and
then the guy was like oh no we we can't
deliver inside we're just gonna leave it
here it's a prefer you it's a prefer us
so you know this is just the new policy
so we're like whoa the world is
different I mean we understand that it's
different now but I guess like just
little things like this like for example
when I bought the rice at the grocery
store and it was like a limit one per
family and like I don't know like now
that they can't bring in packages like
furniture packages into the house it's
just little things like that where I'm
like whoa things are different but yeah
so that's kind of the plan today is to
build Isaac's bedroom furniture and yeah
I'm gonna show you a little bit of what
we've been doing for starters I have
been going in on this this bathroom and
closet so I actually set up the whole
vanity thing this is I think as cute as
it's gonna get because I don't know we
got a lot of stuff and I don't know I
got this at IKEA before they closed the
doors and we were actually able to shop
in person this actually used to be a
candle and I melted off all the wax and
then I cleaned it and now it's like a
little jar I was really proud of myself
when I did that it does that in the old
house so it came with me ready to be a
jar so I organized Casey side and then I
organized my side and I also lined all
of the drawers look how freaking crazy I
am this is how bored I am guys I
actually organized my Floss Picks all
nice and neat and perfect in this
Tiffany box and I keep it in there I
also did all the other drawers I lined
them all see voila
and then I organized under here I mean
that's not organized yet but I'm
eventually planning on getting a vanity
table to be right there with like a
mirror and stuff so once I get a vanity
oh that's gonna be moved
and there's nothing over here he's just
extra stuff okay that's not special but
I also so me and Casey what we did is we
cleaned out this whole shower we also
changed the showerhead to that water
filter showerhead so I could like filter
the water so we cleaned the whole shower
we dried it really nice and neat and
then we sprayed this stuff to make the
tile like water repellent because they
didn't seal the tile when they gave us a
house but now if water is on here it
will it will repel so that we did that
that took a couple hours to do also I
ended up putting this filter it's like
window filter on some of the windows so
I did this one the one over here the
toilet room and then I did Isaac's
bathroom and I think that's it that's
all the film I had left but yeah see did
that that took that this frickin project
took a lot longer than I wanted because
I only had a box cutter so I do not
recommend doing this if you only have a
box cutter in hand by an exacto knife
that will help you alright the closet
this also took a long time to do but
Isaac and I built this drawer
he helped me it was freaking awesome so
you know the how they say like you can
really test your relationship with
someone if you build IKEA furniture
together
well me and Isaac pass because not once
did we get on each other's nerves or get
frustrated it was awesome
like he was such a good helper like he's
a good partner so we both tackled this
baby together so I'm pretty sure it's
gonna be me and him Casey to actually
all three of us are gonna be building
his Isaac's furniture today from Ikea so
that was like a really great starter
point and like a little like the tester
like to just kind of get him to be
warmed up to a building IKEA furniture
and he was really good so I'm proud of
my boy for this all right now look at
this actually I'm like which one should
I open I organized all my PJs and my
pants
and my workout stuff and my swim stuff
and my socks stuff and then up here is
my underwear my bras well I'm not going
to show you because it's private I ended
up fixing this a bit more and then I did
Casey's pants and then Casey's shorts
and then all of this stuff so here his
socks some more socks he actually did
this whole drawer on his own and I was
like hey good job man
and then his pj's his underwear his
muscle shirt and then some beanies and
ties so yeah that was like a whole day's
work there actually like two days I
don't know I have like a TD or something
because every time I start the project I
end up like dabbling in it a little bit
and then I kind of get distracted or
bored or something and then I'll go and
do like another part so simultaneously I
was doing the drawers and the kitchen I
mean what the bathroom I was doing like
the bathroom stuff lining it and like
organizing and fixing everything and at
the same time I was doing the drawers in
my closet I don't know like I just
jumped back and forth but that's what we
did here here's some of the IKEA stuff
that just came in for Isaac's bedroom
what else oh do we do
hey my boy yeah you doing some homework
yeah how's that going nice take a
picture picture your homework and then
upload it yeah that's cool you're
excited for a bedroom set cuz this is
gonna be the last time we see it like
this hopefully we get it all done today
yeah you're finally gonna have your own
bedroom set we should have built first I
don't know what do you want to build to
build the chair the two the easiest
thing on down that's pretty easy and
then build the bed yeah you see how
echoey your room is gonna be that it go
anywhere nice
you'll share and then the dressers and
then a bit whatever you want
we'll figure it out have you eaten
breakfast no maybe I first so he could
get some strength yeah okay
oh I organized the laundry stuff I also
had to move the Shelf up because it was
not enough room I'm just showing you
guys my entire house like literally
everything about it just little things
here and there they all light up in time
especially when you're organizing these
for me like I get in the zone and I'm
like yes this is all it's like there's
like a slow moment move just like a slow
mo what I can't speak today man there's
a slow moment slow movement moment my
brain fart I don't even know what I'm
trying to say I need coffee
forget it oh I was trying to say I get
into the zone when I organize that's it
whatever anyway moving on good morning
I know I'm like I can't my brain can't
brain today yeah it's not raining so
true
yeah good mornings oh hi he's also
sleepy okay what else did we do I'm
trying to show them everything we've
been doing the last five days you find
yourself with less energy since the
quarantine it's nothing no actually I
feel a lot more productive and a lot
more motivated and I don't know like I
feel like because I have the time now I
can utilize the time and I don't feel
like I guess in the past I get too
overwhelmed with everything I need to do
that I just cave in I'm like I just kind
of like implode a little bit where I'm
like well I'm just gonna be in bed for
an extra hour or whatever and then I
can't get anything done but now with the
quarantine stuff happening I feel like
there's no pressure so now I'm free to
actually do the things I need to do
because like I'm not overwhelmed that's
a quote okay no I think I feel quite the
opposite I feel like there's nothing
and it just feels like very low-energy
yes you have to be like very
self-initiative now I know we totally
switched cuz in regular world
we're totally the opposite like usually
I'm just like oh I don't know I gotta do
these a million things or I need to vlog
I haven't blogged in a long time and I'm
just like oh why is it such a chore to
do the things I need to do now that I
don't have to do the things I do I don't
know what it is but it forced to be a
housewife and you're like yeah yeah I
think this is I'm in my element okay
thank you are be a housewife then a
career woman I'm a boy well you're
already for breakfast would you like to
be a house kick both your parents want
to be house parents true Oh cute though
that's super cute so I think is a mega
extrovert and he is hating it here just
the two of us I think it was funnier
when when the whole Chan clan was here
huh ah the house is alive there was like
so much noise lot chatter and I totally
get it because I grew up in a house full
of people and the very small moments in
my childhood whenever like everyone
would be gone and I'd be all alone I'm
like oh my god this is weird like this
is this feels like a natural to me to
not have anyone I have no noise so I
totally understand you I this I get how
you're feeling
yeah have you been experiencing the
quarantine am i correct that you're
going crazy oh my gosh I thought you
farted it's the door thing I was like
wow you're getting comfortable around
the camera just hanging in there you're
hanging in there have you been
facetiming your friends a lot yeah man
FaceTime friends yesterday snow but the
day before yesterday and it hmm that's
cool back to the things that we were
doing I don't think we did anything doc
Monday
you tell us what changed what what what
are we looking at steps with the n/m
mouth mounting the soundboard thank you
baby yes Oh mounting the mirror yes
that's right
good job Casey you did that all on your
own
okay can I just say he did it all on his
own so that means I might be handy if
you force so annoying because every
second that he was just like well I
don't know how to do this how do you do
it oh my baker wait it out it was just a
lot of me trying to not coddle him and
be like listen you can do this on your
own you figured it out good job Bors I
anything else
it's just I'm just way too lazy regular
oh yeah
you're just too used to having your
handheld so you're not used to actually
needing to figure things out and it's
all my fault I have caused this in our
relationship where I'm just like two
into everything and that has gotten you
accustomed to being like well I can't do
anything unless she tells me what to do
so we gotta break that that's not
healthy true no I mean I think being a
house owner to a homeowner house or a
homeowner oh yeah but no one ever says
house owner feels a homeowner yeah but I
thought what you meant yeah I go where I
meant to do it she's I don't know
anyways
hmmm I said I showed them a lot of the
stuff we did upstairs but did I miss
this oh you're right I forgot okay I'll
show them in a second
breweries thanks I forgot homeowner like
homeowner oh yeah now that I'm a
homeowner I do feel more inclined to get
more handy and be more like on top of
things around the home because when
you're renting I really didn't care
yeah when we're renting I was the only
one doing things yeah well I will just
tell the landlord and let him figure it
out yeah and you'll figure it out but
now now it's like there's no landlord
and I and it's a woken something in me
then I'm like I got I gotta I gotta step
it up a bit
yeah well I'm glad that have you seen me
step up
yeah for sure that's what I'm saying I'm
glad I'm not trying to sound sarcastic
if I was true
I really am blood and I'm not letting go
of the kitchen either I'm still doing
the kitchen stuff yeah you've been
killing it hook it up well actually I
have been more involved in the kitchen
too yeah yeah because the kitchen just
is like part of the whole house and like
the whole family it's not like secluded
out in the corner in the kitchen though
I do I mean I kind of have to it's so
small I used to completely avoid the
kitchen I would never even open the
refrigerator I would just be like oh no
no no what's in there that's a whole new
world I'm not trying to explore it but
now that it's like all part of one thing
it's just me that easier for me to care
about the kitchen too so I'm constantly
cleaning things I'm constantly like
loading up or unloading the dishwasher
I'm actually going to the refrigerator
now like it's it's crazy
like a
actually use my kitchen I don't know
it's worse me happy handy enough around
that house opportunity beautiful that's
why we belong together booze no yeah we
fill each other's the emptiness yeah now
it's your turn to let me figure out some
food stuff and then not oh well not let
me like not coddle me with it it's not
as fun cooking doing the quarantines I'm
missing ingredients and stuff and didn't
buy any onions we're just like panic
buying the other day or like we just
need me we need meat or you've got
nothing but meat nourish and it's all
frozen I remember asking you in the
grocery store - I'm like what are we
gonna eat all this meat with and you're
like I don't know there's just a weenie
protein that's fine and I'm like uh
right you need both yeah
I've been I've been working out - so I'm
like I might come out of this quarantine
like pretty nice yeah we don't have any
vegetables so I should my mom stocked up
on vegetables we just don't have the
classic onions don't barely have any
garlic in your like flavor stuff our
aromatics you know man garlic and ginger
yeah speaking of breakfast Oh breakfast
tacos so do you guys remember that
emergency taco kit that we bought the
last time we saw each other so that is
still been going strong like there's so
much meat left
we finished the Thursday as in case you
turned them into those more like little
chips issues yeah tortilla chips they're
really bad they're really really really
hard that the FBI was thick
the third the a was thick and it was
kind of scaled to begin with so and then
when I made the chips it just got me I
just made stale chips and there's the
are I know it to be completely honest I
still
go to that restaurant on stay open
because the emergency taco kit thing it
was i don't women because they were
cooking away but it was not the greatest
greatest meal all panic buying emergency
kids talking kids and they were all
panic cooking cooking yeah yes so the
stuff came out like the meat came out
pretty dry pretty chewy then chop it up
yeah I was like chopped up with really
big chunks which again I understand I
get it it's fine
they at least it's still feeding us and
it's giving us sustenance no breakfast
tacos for you I'm just saying we gotta
finish nope yeah you're right yeah
survival mode I've been trying to
ingrain times ik like you gotta finish
everything you can't throw anyway every
paper towel matters every square for the
paper matters rain every drop so good
job you Vic he's good boy oh yeah look
this it's this photo right before they
left I I bent it too much so I was
trying to make the reflection go away
but yeah to us me that's Casey Kerry
Diana Zack and done yet
these girls or sisters
you were there but you weren't in the
photo I was at Harbor yeah you were the
one taking the picture baby you forgot
look at how beautifully framed and taken
this photo is it's the best framed photo
good job Isaac he took it
alright guys do we see this this is part
of the thermostat that Isaac and I
hooked up upstairs I think you know
you've been like the best greatest
helper let's go
let's go we got the nest we have the
nest good job baby
you helped me set this up and it was
awesome and then he had some really
great ideas too because I was like what
if we built what if we drilled in the
holes over here he's like no it makes
more sense of with drilloid over here
and I'm like you're right so he's been a
really great helper
I appreciate you baby mmm
I set this up that I've had I bought it
at mini so so long ago and it smells so
good it's been making the whole house
smell great if you're wondering what it
smells like in here this is what it
smells like are you guys weird like me
where sometimes you just wonder I wonder
what that here's not like for some
reason that I have these stuff so I
don't know ever since I was a kid I
remember Nickelodeon ones had this like
scratch-and-sniff TV you should like I
don't know it's like a special event
oh man I'm out of breath oh it was like
a special event where if you're like
write them in and they'll mail you a
postcard
and then during this like particular
time and date we would be watching a
show like everywhere all the kids around
the country would be watching watching
the show together and then when they
tell you to scratch and sniff this one
part then like you can smell the show or
whatever I think that really like stayed
with me because ever since then I would
always think about like what do these
smell like remember cases sometimes
they'll be like I wonder what like 1953
smell like yeah I don't know what Game
of Thrones smells like yeah smells no
better campfire vo
yeah an iron smell link of the blizzard
Starbucks Game of Thrones time you're
right oh yeah this is a cup hygiene oh
yeah
we have a meme where they forgot the
Starbucks cup on set you're so funny
okay let's eat well you're about to eat
we got to make some food this has been
the story of breakfast he finishes and
then we finally start eating cuz that's
true we get something we get massive oh
yeah that somethin else I've been doing
every morning I have been making avocado
toast cuz and we picked up a whole bunch
of avocados from his tree and now we're
down to two before oh yeah we're doing
breakfast about this but yesterday I
opened and peeled Lucy I never do
kitchen stuff but I've been doing this
stuff see that counts that help you're
handy and then I'm in the kitchen
peeling avocados and making avocado
toast anyway so yesterday is more round
well-rounded people we are this
quarantine is helping us as a family so
when I killed it everything it was
actually not fully ripe so we googled it
we're like how do we make it more right
and they suggested oh it's still not
right guys ready yeah it shouldn't hold
off on a taco breakfast then but yet
some of these guys what we googled
amazing exciting good but we both rules
is that you cover it in lemon juice or
lime juice and we had lemon and then you
wrap it in saran wrap and then you put
in the fridge and you wait for it to
soften but I guess 24 hours is not long
enough I don't think these are ready
either they're kind of not fully squishy
ones I used for the avocado toast just
so happen to be really really ripe so
you still want taco breakfast
[Music]
all right after breakfast we got some
more packages so these big old boxes
here whoo yes moving on they are our new
couch for the upstairs it's a bright red
couch that has cup holders and
everything for three of us and they
recline you excited for a reclining
couch up in the loft yeah me too
okay but I remembered I was in the
middle of talking about that thing over
there and then I forgot so let me finish
that we ended up mounting the sound
board onto this thingy so do you guys
remember when I was talking about the
l-brackets so here they are
Casey and I put it together we had to
take the TV down oh my god look at all
this mess but we had to take down the TV
and then mount the soundboard attachment
to the TV and do all this cable
management stuff and then we also duct
it is so ghetto but we don't tape the
thingamabob er to this thingamabob er so
we can have power and then the only cord
showing is this white one because
eventually this Xbox is gonna live
upstairs so this will not be a problem
once we move upstairs we're upstairs
okay we got to start moving things and
we're gonna start building you ready to
build yeah oh yeah you're you're
building but it's not moving it doesn't
work
[Music]
that's pretty good
look at that movement he's moving his
hips and everything and intended your
foot to be backward
alright okay let's get some work done
all right
new couch is all set up this is super
cool it has cup holders and has storage
on each side check this out ready three
two one now this is the life so the plan
is we're getting rid of that we're
putting a TV there and this is gonna be
the new family room movie theater
velvety look yeah movie theater exactly
popcorn and drinks ready dude so you've
done using the restroom because you're
pretty loud smacking other pellets yeah
super comfy I like it I almost went what
the two seater one does it look like it
was wide enough to fit all three of us
but do you know how incredibly difficult
it is to find a three seater recliner I
couldn't find any there were three it's
either four and then only the ends or
client or two yeah it was annoying hey
guys so it's been a few hours later
here's Isaac's bedroom there is no bed
frame because you know why they forgot
to deliver it they only delivered the
drawers which is ridiculous foot here
look Isaac and Casey built the two
drawers that are supposed to go under
the bed frame
but what happened Isaac they forgot it
they forgot it huzzah whose fault is it
the delivery man so remember how earlier
I said that they actually said like oh
sorry we can't go inside
really they actually spoke to you what'd
they say I opened the door just I can
hear them I'm leading stuff on our house
so I was like hey good morning guys
thanks delivering the stuff being all
nice and stuff and then like pretty much
cuts me off and he's like oh sorry sir
we're not allowed to continue bringing
in the stuff into the house
sorry for the inconvenience and they
just kind of bounce the raft of that so
that theory is maybe I open the door
prematurely they were just thinking
they're gonna drop off all the delivery
stuff but since I opened the door to
them they're like Google divorce and
then they're like we got it bounced and
maybe they forgot how did the panic they
forgot to finish bring in the extra
couple boxes that we're missing right
now yeah so we were able to build the
slat stuff that goes for the bed both
the nightstands and I already showed you
the drawers this is left so this is a
bench that's supposed to go right here
and it has like little drawers and this
is gonna be here so we are going to take
a lunch break because we are hungry and
tired oh and also our couch is done too
look at this
oh wait I already showed you that never
mind forget that I forgot what I
recorded cuz bin hours later you really
like that couch
it's so nice I like it
wait you're in Isaac's but I don't
matter three two one oh my gosh she
loves it
oh no you don't have work trace because
I also ordered some TV trays so we could
eat up here that's that's how
comfortable in flannery classic 1950s
American degenerate style yep exactly
frozen dinners
that's the plan actually no I'm looking
at this I'm like maybe we should get
different trays for our lap because the
TV trays have great cancel the order
yeah because they do have other kind of
TV trays where it's like a tray tray and
you can tell me over here laughs like
this where you want a tray we had to
bring the thing back and have a tray in
front of you which eat like this sure
got rid of the tray that you said that's
true we did have a different tray but I
forgot we also built this for your room
oh yeah
this is a very first thing we built oh
my god I just got half of everything I
know
oh he doesn't have his desk because they
sold out of the desk so now we have to
look for another one but you got your
chair yeah lunchtime all right so we
finished our lunch we had hot dogs we're
upstairs and loved enjoying the new
couch and guess what we did we set up
the TV you know it's funny you know how
this whole time I've been talking about
removing those coverings or cabinets and
moving it to the garage so then we can
have the TV set up here because back
when we used to think about this we
would think that the TV's too high and
it wouldn't be comfortable and also like
there's a potential of it tipping over
the stairs and that kind of gets a
little scary which is still a real fear
but we thought like hey what if we don't
have to do all that work and then we
just avoided TV here so what do you guys
think about you kind of like the height
a little high but I'm actually enjoying
the type differences just like you're
like kind of like reclining back more
and like you're like satisfaction and
watching something that's comfortable
true it is a bit high but it's not too
uncomfortable at least not now we
haven't tried watching anything yet but
as of right now I'm like I could
probably live with this so we were
talking instead of removing this whole
thing we can create a hole back here and
then have like some sort of opening down
there so then through the cabinets we
can drill another hole make an actual
electrical outlet that way we don't have
to live with this weird cable because
there's already power on the
side so we can just grab the power put
it here you already know how to do it
since your dad talk to you yes we could
also be facetiming so that's the idea
for that no no I'm not mad at it like it
drinks yeah and then we have like this
thing goes super deep like my entire arm
could fit in here so really your entire
I was gone we got I don't know a lot of
snacks you're trying to put in there to
to buy your head doesn't fit you can't
get going to the dude what if we get
slow in here no oh no that'd be horrible
that's too mean but yeah we have the
Apple TV set up the sound bar set up and
we're about to enjoy a nightcap the
office guys yeah oh yeah we have been on
the office bench on aid the office bench
Isaac is enjoying it now you're old
enough to actually enjoy the show which
is awesome because when you were younger
we'd be watching it you'd be like okay
I'm out of here
how do you enjoy the show it's pretty
funny so it's a great way to kill time
but you're like cracking up man like you
actually get a lot of the jokes and you
you pick up on a lot of the subtleties
that makes a joke so genius where I'm
like well Isaac you're maturing school
alright so movie time leave it all the
way back so the nice surprise we legit
have a bed what a setup that's sick
yeah all right I'm gonna get to my seat
real quick
excuse me sorry excuse me sorry make
sure you like and subscribe so follow
their Instagram link in the bio
[Music]